what's so funny man when I was uh
attending my little [ __ ] rich kid
School in [ __ ] uh St John's Wood the
American School of London like literally
a [ __ ] block or two down the road
from there was like a properly hard
[ __ ] scary British public school
called Quentin kineston and they used to
beat us up all the time like it was so
fun dude Don't Go Near there there's
like I don't know it's a 2K oh no you
know and we would get mugged all the
time too like uh you got mugged I did
get my dollar time and it was so crazy
like I think a traumatic experience
and it wasn't it it didn't happen all
the time but I got mugged at least
three times properly and by properly I
mean knife points or I got a knife in my
pocket give me Gizzy watch and heard
something like that like that that
happened like but it's either I have a
knife or like yeah like give me that
skateboard or I'm gonna [ __ ] beat you
up right now and just give him the
skateboarding games
dude took my skateboard and then made me
buy a bag
are you serious and I'll give you all
your money you can have your board back
how much
oh my god dude
how old
yeah you're like 23.
yeah I was like I'm thinking I was like
13 maybe 14. I feel like you've never
told that story before I've never told
I've never admitted that to another
living
Souls certain parts of London can be
very rough yeah and especially because
we would go around skateboarding and
like our like the skate spots are not
necessarily in nice Parts but we will
just love skateboarding we want to go
ride that and so that puts us where the
[ __ ] guys are that that Hat's cool
I'll take it yeah yeah it was my
favorite hat I'm one of them one time I
got mugged
I mean that's like a life-changing event
it's happened like seven times but the
steaks are like kind of lower like they
don't have like the guns now they're
starting to have guns in England though
oh yeah this
people someone got shot the other week
by ours I mean it's there's more guns
out with it it's knives that's the
problem in the UK you know what I mean
there was a
11 year old girl let's get stabbed in
the neck and it's at the city center
last year
I see me in this year that it's just
some of the stuff you read about there's
people getting stabbed left right inside
London Birmingham a wish for her you
know a lot about it in London and
Birmingham people getting stabbed
well obviously it's not as it's not as
bad as guns yeah he's got to be this
close to someone to actually stabbed
them holding me yeah I just stands from
Six Mile Away with a sniper and shoot
someone we had did that America with the
[ __ ] guns man them AR-15s what
stay away from me
it's not red
um I think that clip was awesome but not
as awesome as my new book a hard kick in
the nuts what I've learned from a
lifetime of terrible decisions which is
out September 27th and if you pre-order
it right now you can get the autographed
copy so get on it man pre-order my book
it's not gonna waste your time because
I'm proven dude New York Times
bestseller my first book's Five star
rated on Amazon and I have no doubt this
one will be too so get the autograph
copy right now by pre-ordering it at
stevo.com
yeah dude